hola que tal un cordial saludo a todas y
todos les habla pablo gómez barrios y es
un gran placer estar con ustedes acá en
la represa cibernética hoy me acompañan
rufo valencia y leonardo gimeno equipo
reducido masculino y bueno pues espero
con ganas de trabajar no un viernes que
es el lo demasiado cool y no muy cool y
masculino es bien grande no entonces
este es el castor cibernético de hoy
viernes 26 de octubre en vivo y en
directo por facebook live un cordial
saludo allá a todos los que están en
este momento en línea y también sale en
vivo en nuestro sitio internet theresay
net punto sea y en
youtube un caluroso saludo entonces a
todos los que nos están escuchando
gracias por su agradable compañía y
bueno leonardo leonardo rufo bienvenidos
un gusto en estar hace tiempo que estoy
más contento que perro con dos colas
sobre una represa o como dirían en
colombia que marrano estrenando lazo
pero preguntan ahora porque a mí me
parece importante alguien le preguntó
alguna vez a un perro si estaría
contento con dos colas porque uno lo
dice como si fuera un hecho sí bueno hay
tantas arbitrariedades en el mundo que
esta es una de las tantas en el
remanente al final el coxis y hay un
remanente de esa de esa pérdida cola
imagínate tú y bueno pues se contentos y
contento de estar nuevamente aquí en
estudio y con ustedes y acá con el
castor cibernético y todo con los que
nos están escuchando allá del otro lado
o escucha viendo del otro lado del
micrófono y se pasó javier gonzález ya
está mirando no se nos dice hola
cordial saludo javier un gusto un gusto
saber que anda por allá del otro lado
abierta en guadalajara
de guadalajara en méxico una laguna
[Risas]
antiguamente
hundiendo la catedral etcétera
hay muchos trabajos de reforzamiento de
la catedral que bueno la última vez que
estuve en méxico porque vive ahí me metí
en las catacumbas esas y estaban
trabajando así que me imagino que van a
hacer todos los posibles si no según de
venecia a que están también en un lago
ahí
de a poco se hunde no parece que no
fíjate es va aumentando el nivel de agua
el problema el problema es ese pero ya
están haciendo una especie de diques
especiales que impiden el problema es la
maria si entonces que cuando la maria
viene y sube entra porque hay una
entrada a un canal ahí por donde entra
todo el agua y ha dicho ya que donde
está construida a venecia entonces
notaron que si efectivamente que cada
vez que la marea subía se inundaba una
buena parte de la ciudad entonces
decidieron se llevaron muchos años
construyendo ese dique es un dique muy
especial que cuando la marea sube se
cierra y deja solo el pase abre sólo
para dar paso a las embarcaciones y
cuando la marea baja bueno pues se
retira nuevamente para que pueda haber
una una circulación marítima o fluvial
como la llamamos más fluida y
envolviendo está a guadalajara el sí sí
sí creo que en realidad es de 73
refrenar de pablo pero me parece que sí
trabaja en su taxi sí sí sí esto debe
ser un momento de pausa bien el programa
por sí sí en el auto mezclando bueno
antes de entrar de lleno acá de darle
rienda suelta al castor mensajero al
castor cibernético no sé si tienen
algunas noticias inéditas necesitan o lo
que le damos la atención fue
oleada de bombas maltrechas en eeuu me
parece realmente de otros siglos me
parece efectivamente me parece de una de
una locura y más en la que entre
comillas la capital del mundo nos parece
extraño sumamente está al parecer ya
tuvieron una persona estaba viendo
ahorita en las noticias que ya tienen
una persona detenida que si está
relacionado o no de tenerla
si a mí lo que me llama la atención y
que no entra nadie llama la atención a
nadie es justamente como las fronteras
geográficas y las las ideas de países
han se están desvaneciendo tan
rápidamente y gracias a las nuevas
tecnologías la verdad con la que la
comunicación funciona algo que me llame
la atención fue que esta mañana esteban
declaró oficialmente su apoyo al
candidato
brasil jair bolsonaro bueno control
entonces no me sorprende para nada que
apoye a bolsonaro claro entonces lo que
también me llama la atención es que como
pueden ver acá en radio canadá se
preguntan si brasil va a escoger a un
fascista al gobierno en brasil
y justamente lo que está estas bombas
as injustamente recuerdan como decías
hace otro siglo como esos grupos de
choque de las camisas negras en italia
las camisas pardas en alemania es decir
se van el discurso oficial
va promoviendo justamente ese tipo de
expresiones que en eeuu por más la más
grande fue esa esa marcha en
charlottesville en la que está toda la
ultraderecha la derecha fascista
literalmente en que la historia vuelve a
repetirse y claro tuvo una persona
muerta etcétera entonces este fenómeno
es y también se puede conectar este
desprecio de trump por la prensa y el
ataque constante
despedazamiento de este periodista en
árabe en el consulado en el amor
entonces estamos viendo como esa
influencia de este nuevo nerón digámoslo
así que está en roma que es washington
que está inflando a todo el mundo
no es ésta la tercera guerra mundial
no no lo sé mira que no sé por qué
porque me parece digamos la remontada de
esta gente que no tiene ningún reparo en
decir oficialmente va a ser necesario
los voy a matar a todos y ese tipo de
cosas o sea me parece como que es la
exacerbación de la violencia y es yo
entiendo que hace falta la alternancia
política yo entiendo que hace falta el
cambio no entiendo qué hace falta aires
nuevos en los países pero esto me parece
demasiado extremo me parece como que no
tiene sentido y que la gente no pueda
verlo me parece que es ya es una
cuestión de muy profunda el hecho de que
la gente no se dé cuenta o no quiera
darse cuenta o esté buscándolo el cambio
desde ese punto de vista yo veo en las
redes sociales argentinas por ejemplo en
argentina se registran recortes en
educación en salud
en las cuestiones básicas y la gente
sigue echando le sigue echando la culpa
a lo que pasó o sea el presente les
importa muy poco yo entiendo que lo que
pasó fue nefasto que hubieron que la
corrupción estuvo al pie del cañón
durante un montón de años pero
justificar y en este caso justificar
digamos trump presidente bolsonaro en
brasil el hecho de justificar esta esta
violencia votando a personas que
realmente siembran el terror me parece
me parece que no tiene sentido no ser
bueno
diríamos que es el regreso del péndulo o
sea de que en un momento en américa
latina entre otros pues un gobierno de
izquierdas durante una cierta época y
después bueno ahora son los gobiernos de
derecha los que los que regresan se
diríamos que la gente en un momento dado
se decepciona de los gobiernos en el
poder
y quieren un cambio y en ese momento lo
que se presente más diferente a lo que
lo que está en el poder es lo que ellos
optan por por elegir un claro ahí va
tocó el tema de la alternancia política
es necesaria esta viene o sea 30 años de
una persona en el poder no es bueno para
nadie aunque sea el mejor gobierno del
mundo o sea es necesario alternar la ley
para que el para que la tanto la
política como la sociedad se renueven
piensen en cosas diferentes pero el
hecho de poner gente o sea evidentemente
no hay otra alternativa en el cambio o
sea o es más de lo mismo o es lo
absolutamente opuesto y es posible que
esto del cambio sea más bien una una
ficción del propio sistema es decir si
vemos por ejemplo la situación de los
derechos civiles en eeuu tanto bajo
demócratas como republicanos en nombre
de alternancia se han ido distribuir se
han ido compartiendo el gobierno ha ido
tomando uno y otro pero en los hechos
las líneas mayores de la
a la política es evidente no han
cambiado la clase dominante que estaba
aquí es que apoya estos sectores los
hermanos casos por ejemplo ellos han
estado golpeando sus millones
tranquilamente es decir que es hasta qué
punto una alternancia en realidad
significa nada más que cambiar el chófer
del autobús sin cuestionarse a dónde
está yendo autobús en que están exactos
no miren digamos lo que yo noto desde
desde particular punto de vista que es
mi burbuja es que no se mira el plan
político se mira a la persona para
cambiar de persona está bien o sea no
bolsonaro por ejemplo las cosas que dijo
yo no quiero en general persona con un
dedo y medio ni siquiera dos un dedo
medio de frente pueda votar por una
persona que está prometiendo castigar y
hacer uso de la violencia física para
poder contenerla la historia sea no no
me eligieron a trump porque decía
cualquier cosa
dieron a reuters
en filipinas que prometió ejecutar a
todos los maleantes bueno pues la
naturaleza humana es definitivamente
demasiado compleja
yo creo que es el problema son los
sistemas son los sistemas y bueno pero
los sistemas no son autónomos o sea el
humano el humano
generando esos sistemas y los va
orientando a su guisa
a su forma de ver bueno yo tengo cosas
menos serias por favor si entonces me
estaba viendo
hay 22 notas que me llamaron mucho la
atención esta semana en unas aquí en
aquí en canadá en manitoba en manitoba
dan fuiste en que cultiva cultiva
calabazas se dice como las que
utilizamos en
ahora en el halloween el halloween es la
semana próxima las fiestas fiestas
fiestas empiezan hoy el viernes que
viene venimos disfrazados
por qué
la sorpresa no prometemos nada de
antemano
entonces este señor dancing cultiva
calabazas y cultivan o cualquier
calabaza cultiva calabazas gigantes sí y
tiene una tierra ahí
acerca de winnipeg entonces aquí pueden
ver el tipo de calabaza que él cultiva y
esta calabaza que que fue la que batió
el récord este año por primera vez
cultivo una calabaza de 450 kilogramos
que alcanza un metro de altura y un
metro 20 de ancho
entonces no se sirve si no se ve muy
bien nada habría que habría que es que
mostrarle la imagen en la pantalla en
todo caso el señor se reunió con unos
amigos que podemos ver por aquí que
están que están con ellos y decidió
convertir su calabaza gigante en una
chalupa agregamos un motor le puso un
motor a su calabaza y se desplazado allí
en un lago artificial cerca de donde
singer de manitoba es mejor que la
calabaza de las cenicientas que a las 12
se convertía en un carruaje
encontré la contrataban contrastes
entonces muestra se la ha y está la
calabaza mira esa señora calabaza un 90
señor o la señora calabaza de su playa
y entonces un 450 kilogramos un metro 20
de altura y un metro un metro un metro
de altura y un metro 20 de ancho
entonces pues me pareció curioso esto de
que ya que estamos en halloween de que
haya calabazas tan gigantes la otra nota
es es muy simpática también pero no fue
aquí en canadá fue en bélgica resulta de
que un señor que tiene una tienda en la
que vende estos estos cigarros
electrónicos apeadores bateadores bueno
yo no fumo así que ya no ya no el léxico
no me da para tanto pero díaz porque el
vapor a veces él tiene una tienda de
bateadores y resulta de que en la mañana
como a las 10 de la mañana un sábado el
sábado pasado entraron seis personas de
las cuales dos estaban armadas para
robarle wow y para robarle y el tipo se
les enojó y le dijo mire dice no es no
era ese
no era en la mañana en ayer en la tarde
a las a las tres de la tarde y a esto se
le dijo no es a las tres de la tarde
donde se hacen los robos los robos aquí
se hacen a las seis y media así que por
favor se me van enseguida y regresen a
las seis y media
y después entonces regresaron a las
cinco y media y el tipo el dueño se
recontra enojo y le dijo pero comprendió
un reloj qué es lo que pasa con las
estupideces que ustedes hacen yo les
dije las seis y media afuera y se fueron
nuevamente mientras tanto él llamó la
policía y regresaron a las seis y media
para hacer el robo y ahí los agarró la
policía fíjate que el ratero es tan
obediente bueno si fuera así en perú hay
un escándalo ahí por los célebres
adornos de botes que estaban causando
estragos
así que bueno y estamos ya otra cosa que
me llamó la atención ruso y leonardo es
que recibimos y me sorprendió un informe
de recepción de qué planeta yo no sé no
lamenta brasil y de brasil viene desde
brasil y se le envía a la sección
española radio canadá internacional nos
lo envía
humberto d'urgell de río de janeiro y
humberto nos escuchó
07/07 de este año es el 7 de octubre
julio 7 de julio nos escuchó a las 15
horas en una frecuencia a medio extraña
en 7.310 y nos da un tiempo de 33 33 ya
digamos pasándola jackass y malos o no
entonces él escuchó el programa entonces
me preguntaba así porque hay en
latinoamérica creo que es en chile no sé
dónde que hay una pequeña radio que
retoma nuestros programas y los
retransmite por las ondas a un saludo
entonces a los amigos en chile
aparte de lo que duele sea pablo sobre
este saludo por ahí es una onda que
quedó en el espacio y que justo bajó en
ese momento y este hombre encontró saber
de qué estábamos hablando en ese momento
de que julio de qué año era 18 2018 7 de
7 el 18 está escrito acá en blanco y
negro
18 que es lo que estábamos haciendo
programas detalles del programa news and
music
entonces es viejo porque nosotros hace
mucho que no ponemos música y tampoco
damos noticias bueno entonces eso dentro
de las curiosidades de esta semana muy
bien los entremos de lleno ya con
nuestros mensajes de nuestros oyentes a
ver rufo algo algo hay para mira y se
está a punto sus pases y aquí de pruebas
directas de adn que indican el
medicamento que más le conviene a su
salud
gregorio dice pruebas directas de adn
que si el camino
al infierno está pavimentado con oro de
aquí las armas a las armas de exterminio
masivo silencioso no hay más que un paso
cuando el que haga en manos de
consorcios militares se acabó el tiempo
y eres muy tarde entonces un poco
aterrado del nuestro amigo gregorio
porque se pueda utilizar el adn para
para calibrar los medicamentos para las
personas si x la gran mensaje en este
caso ese neurólogo experto en epilepsia
ofrece consultas gratis en español desde
saskatchewan lunas rojas dice hola soy
madre un chico 17 años actualmente mi
consulta es la siguiente diagnóstico de
epilepsia focal frontal según el doctor
es muy leve que me y poco se eleve de
epilepsia sus medicamentos son buenos a
los nombres y se toman por la mañana y
por la noche estas pastillas para dormir
y después de 3 encefalogramas no se
pueden diagnosticar pero en el cuarto se
visualizó dice la pregunta es necesito
explicación más real por favor ya que el
doctor no explica demasiado muchas
gracias
atenta a su información
labruna que en realidad tendría que
ponerse en contacto con este experto en
saskatchewan que hace evidentemente
consultas gratis en español
probablemente pueda hacer una consulta
vía internet para consultar puntualmente
con todos los detalles que nos da porque
nos da los detalles de los de los
remedios y tal creo que estaba pues
podría ser una de las opciones ya claro
así porque nosotros no podemos aconsejar
la sobre todo en esos campos en el campo
médico entre otros que es muy delicado
así que puede comunicar con él no sé si
hay por ahí algún mensaje de las
personas que están en línea
gonzález con garay que está con nosotros
en línea dice bueno sobre la noticia
reduzca su huella ecológica sembrando
árboles es una alternativa muy tangible
para revertir el cambio climático y por
ende la reducción de emisiones de
bióxido de carbono sembrando árboles
dice bióxido y sin ley dióxido y dióxido
dice si reflexionamos un poquito vemos
que todo lo que consumimos se
necesitamos proviene de la naturaleza es
decir la tierra de tal modo que es
urgente que nos apliquemos todos los
humanos y hagamos una simbiosis con la
naturaleza acá en guadalajara o la vive
en guadalajara tenemos la obligación por
lo menos de tener un árbol por cada
habitación interesantemente interesante
no lo sabíamos había muchos saludos
hasta hasta montreal amigos de radio
ganan troceada bueno yo tengo acá la
causa de la caravana de emigrantes son
las políticas de estados unidos en
honduras héctor lerín rueda dice en 1954
el presidente guatemalteco reformista
que quería hacer una necesaria y urgente
reforma agraria jacobo arbenz fue
derrocado por estados unidos con apoyo
de los corruptos gobiernos de honduras y
nicaragua se desató una masacre de
100.000 muertos y se impuso un
y militarismo en el país y en el 2009 el
presidente manuel sal a celaya un
reformista moderado también fue
derrocado con apoyo de eeuu hillary
clinton secretaria de estado reconoció
que ella hizo todo lo posible para que
no le fuera regresado el poder a zelaya
que sucedió más dictaduras que tienen a
honduras unidos a honduras digo sumido
en la pobreza y en la violencia así de
simple el autor es experto en temas
latinoamericanos en la unam de méxico y
esto se añade justamente el
reconocimiento de eeuu del fraude
electoral en la última elección que fue
documentado por distintos operadores la
oea misma dijo que no era una elección
transparente se de golpe como en mexico
se apagan las computadoras y avala un
otro resultado y está este personaje de
presidente en honduras así es bueno era
un comentario de héctor lerín rueda aquí
tengo un justamente lo que decirse
leonardo sobre argentina
noticias mayores recortes y más
impuestos en el presupuesto argentino
aprobado por una comisión de diputados
juan carlos moreno dice estimados no es
verdad que el gobierno argentino haya
logrado la aprobación del presupuesto
2019 lo que se logró es contar con
mayoría en la cámara de diputados para
tratar el presupuesto cosa que está
sucediendo en este momento y se espera
que la votación para la aprobación o el
rechazo el presupuesto presentado por el
gobierno se estima que será mañana
miércoles en la madrugada es decir
anteayer por favor confirme la
información antes de publicarla entonces
es la explicación la aclaración que nos
pide juan carlos moreno y evidentemente
en el título está que fue una comisión
diputados la que aprobó el presupuesto
argentino no el gobierno
bueno no sé si entre las personas que
nos están teniendo por nancy en remedy
vida gracias por todo conectando el zinc
en el pasado lunes y como esta base y
así como siempre desde brasil así que
bueno si ella está cerca desde
y el nancy y sigo pensando en el cine
perdón el tema de la carta que nos llegó
diciendo que escucharon nuestras ondas
cortas desde brasil a ver qué
preguntarle si está cerca si no hay
alguien que nos reproduzca que se pueda
escuchar en onda corta por ahí en el si
nos puede explicar si se está hacia hay
algo parecido a lo que sucede en chile
por esto de hay una pequeña radio que él
retoma nuestros programas y lo re
difunde por las ondas cortas de sal y no
sé dónde se encuentran él si yo sé que
está en brasil pero no sé exactamente en
qué parte de brasil a ver si nos dice
snr sí dónde está y si a ese fenómeno
porque está esta carta que nos llegó con
el informe de recepción que nos
sorprendió un poquitito porque hace ya
desde el 2002 12 que según 24 de junio
que ya no estamos más en las ondas
cortas entonces ésta viene de río de
janeiro en el sic y nos llegó esta
semana muy bueno aquí tengo otro otro
mensaje sobre la noticia cuba dice que
eeuu está tomando el camino de la
confrontación
gregorio dice cuba dice que eeuu está
tomando
la confrontación es a arahal acá no es
más que una cortina de humo orquestada
para confundir a la opinión pública
igual sucede con el embargo que lleva
años sin que les afecte en nada y
encontrar una forma de burlar los sin
costo político dudas estudian el
artículo pequeñas cantidades por miles
de cubanos que viajan exterior desde que
el régimen flexibilizó la salida del
país es el mensaje de gregorio
muchas gracias gregorio ros un pequeño
mensaje de dilekli una gente que sí y él
reacciona a esta noticia que dice uno de
cada cuatro adolescentes bebe en exceso
según informe de salud canadiense es de
le kram comenta encuentra interesante
sus artículos incluso ahí donde a
mejorar mi aprendizaje del español
muchas gracias dice decirle claro bueno
si me fueron muchas gracias por
escucharnos hay muchas personas en todo
caso que no se escuchan yo sé de alguien
en la universidad de montreal creo que
hay una profesora
e invita a sus alumnos a que seguir en
nuestros programas para que para qué
bueno vayan mejorando su español no sé
si nosotros lo ayudamos en eso no tener
momento de escuchar
no sé si es el instituto español hay hay
un instituto que da clase de español que
también utilizaba noticias nuestras para
enseñar así que tenemos una gran
responsabilidad
así es van y tenemos a nuestra amiga en
new brunswick que escucha también
nuestros programas el año la tele y
bueno pues ella también es una
aficionada al español estuvo en españa
recientemente haciendo un curso creo que
fue en el don de salamanca en salamanca
creo que era exacto y bueno entonces a
la cuna de la universidad así increíble
dice dicen dicho que lo que dios nos dio
salamanca no lo pre nombre está sí señor
bueno aquí tengo otro mensaje ese museo
de derechos humanos de winnipeg abre
espacio américa latina
y el mensaje está firmado pero en
realidad tiene una cuenta de internet no
la voy a leer así que buen gesto de los
canadienses si habrá espacio para el
genocidio de un partido político
colombiano así que bueno este es el
mensaje no tengo el nombre dice p h a
under es lo que está firmas y está
firmado yo tengo acá una publicidad que
usa imagen de pablo escobar en toronto
causa controversia entre colombianos en
la ciudad francos sanín y él dice nadie
mandó a los colombianos a vivir a canadá
o si yo soy argentino y vivo en chile
sería ridículo que me ofenda porque
algún local o algo haga referencia a
algo sensible de mi país para el último
mundial de fútbol en tv abierta mente
los conductores decían que querían que
argentina perdiera en cada uno de los
partidos y tuvieron comentarios bastante
desafortunados al respecto
pero el que vino a vivir aquí soy yo
dice frank os anime chileno me obligó es
una estupidez la sociedad estúpida que
estamos teniendo bueno ese es el
comentario de francos a nine que se
indigna bueno por esta indignación
de los colombianos en toronto muchísimas
gracias franco tengo otro mensaje ese
ataque en un politécnico en crimea deja
18 motos y 50 heridos
javier gonzález lugares nos dice muy
desafortunado este atentado sucedido en
el politécnico de crimea pero
generalizando este tipo de actos
violentos a nivel mundial a diario vemos
situaciones similares de mayor o menor
grado como les he comunicado en otros de
mis comentarios acá en guadalajara
méjico casi a diario amanece en cuerpos
humanos envueltos en bolsas negras
william o cruceros de calles importantes
si conclusión la humanidad a nivel
mundial se está deshumanizando bueno ya
era un comentario de javier gonzález
neurales de javier que hay un pequeño
anuncio de 'la y ya dejen de una fiesta
que justamente se va a cabo
en los próximos días es la gente de la
típica que nos hacen saber que el 3
noviembre se presentará la nueva edición
de la típica quien en asia de montreal
entonces ahí vaya la sofía una estuvo
fantástica fantástica la segunda no pude
ir tenía otro compromiso y así pudo ir a
ésta porque es algo para no perderse si
en bueno la que así haya que encontrar
hoy en principio deberíamos tener dos
invitados de toronto que festejan en el
día de los muertos y no nos dieron
noticias entonces pues se perdieron el
programa bueno vamos a ahora a pasar a
los temas que resaltamos porque el
tiempo pasa como agua entre los dedos y
aquí
leonora chapman está ausente hoy pero
ella nos sugiere y les sugiere a todos
nosotros y ustedes una entrevista que
ella hizo con la concejal de la ciudad
de montreal
josefina blanco que estuvo participando
en la octava edición de la semana
hispana d
montreal y turbo valencia por tu parte
tu nos habla del racismo anti
nicaragüense en costa rica es un tema
delicado tan rica nadie en costas si
gano en contratar rico costa rica
bienvenida justamente en el marco de la
semana hispanohablante diálogo y
reconciliación que se llevó a cabo en la
úncia de quebec y montreal la red de
estudios latinoamericanos de montreal
coordinada por una voz conocida por con
sus oyentes o por menos algunos de ellos
víctor armonía se es académico él fue
presentado un panel titulado grandes
debates de la sociedad democracia en
acción y estuve allí y escuché la
presentación de un investigadora
costarricense floriana vi que es que
justamente ella en pre explicó lo que
había sucedido en costa rica en agosto
pasado donde se organizó por primera vez
una manifestación
anti nicaragüense y explicaba que datos
que hay detrás de esa de esa corriente
cómo se justifica que explica más que
todo antes de de manera muy concreta muy
factual entonces ella da cuenta de la
construcción del sujeto nacional
costarricense que digamos es civilizada
en comparación con la barbarie de los
nicaragüenses es un poco como sus en
todas partes entonces los desde los
signos canciones populares la noción de
que costarricenses blanco que es tiene
más es más bien la europa la suiza en
américa central si se le llamó durante
mucho tiempo creo que aún todavía se le
conoce como la suiza de centroamérica es
decir ella hace un inventario de todos
esos ideología más esas esas ideas que
circulan la sociedad y a partir de esas
ideas explica cómo esto desemboca
justamente en esa marcha xenófoba que
también ella vincula en parte con
este discurso antiinmigrante propagado
desde la roma nueva roma desde eeuu
entonces ella ve similitudes parecidos y
como y explica que estamos una época en
que esos discursos que previamente
estaban soterrados que eran sus
subterráneos que no eran bien vistos
públicamente de pronto ganan carta de
ciudadanía en el campo de los discursos
así que eso es lo que le explica y decía
justamente que los canadienses no
conocen o conocen muy poco de lo que
pasa en costa rica y que se vehicula
constantemente esa imagen de que es un
paraíso medioambiental en el medio
ambiente etcétera etcétera entonces una
mirada no una mirada desde que ella dice
que está haciendo justamente esta
investigación como parte de su doctorado
sobre el tema de la discriminación hacia
los inmigrantes de origen ate americano
aquí en canadá y decía ella que es bueno
para poder justamente ante que si está
bien señalar esas esos elementos pero
también hay que ver cómo funcionan esas
dinámicas en nuestros propios países
discriminación de la cual ella misma fue
víctima porque me recuerdo que la última
vez que conversé con florian a ella
había salido a comprar a comprar estaba
viendo con su compañero en televisión en
la casa y él decidió
pues si en largo
tienda y salió de su casa a la tienda y
fue detenida por la policía porque
alguien debiera comprar un dulce y unas
galletas y algo así en la tienda y salió
de su casa a la tienda y fue detenida
por la policía hasta porque
alguien alguien del vecindario llamó a
la policía para decirle que uno
entonces tuvo que explicarle a la
policía quién es exacto que salió de su
casa pues a la tienda como cualquier
persona lo podría hacer pero entonces
porque ella porque es aquí ir a lo que
ella tenía o sea en su en su forma de
vestir y en su físico que la podía
volver sospechosa ante sus vecinos y
ante la policía misma que la aceptó
la noticia fue la que hizo el acto de
confirmación de que esto sucede es decir
que desfila dos días exactos y entonces
pues no se conoce muy bien el tema y lo
ha vivido en carne propia tierra en
floriana bueno mi querido leonardo
gimeno diga usted acá hoy nos habla de
energía alternativa renovable si el tema
es el problema que esto que esto produce
porque nosotros tenemos entendido que
bueno lo que estamos haciendo con el
planeta es desastroso entonces hay que
a dar una vuelta de página y comenzar
con este tipo de energías renovables
alternativas limpias verdes o como
quieran llamarles las dos que salen hay
un montón pero las dos que siempre
sobresalen son la eólica y la energía
eléctrica está bien y el problema ahora
es que se ha detectado que estos dos
tipos de energía también son
contaminantes en la eólica y perdón la
foto sintética digamos con los paneles
solares y el tema es que es fantástica
la energía en el caso de la eólica se
comprobó que hay contaminación hay
contaminación de suelos hay
contaminación de paisajes entre entre
otros y eso daña el ecosistema y
puntualmente con los paneles solares el
problema es que se hacen y cada vez hay
más porque es energía barata sustentable
pero
nadie habla del reciclaje de los paneles
que tienen una vida útil y que están
compuestos con un montón de cosas que
son cáncer y afectadas que duraban mucho
tiempo los mejores ahora 20 30 40 años
pero en algún momento hay que sacarlos
hay que desarmar los hay que reciclar
los y eso las grandes compañías de
reciclaje no lo están haciendo porque no
les es rentable por hoy hoy por hoy no
hay cantidad como para que sea rentable
y están encargadas de bueno de reciclar
todas estas cosas de electrónicas que
tenemos entonces no les conviene y eso
se está acumulando y se está juntando y
en algún momento puede llegar a ser muy
nocivo para nuestro planeta quizás más
que otros tipos de energía entonces
plantean un estudio este estudio plantea
la posibilidad de la necesidad de tomar
cartas en el asunto de parte de los
gobiernos para que cuando piensen en
energía solar y en los paneles que
piensen en gestionar de manera que las
empresas que crean estos paneles sean
capaces después de su que su vida útil
esté terminada de hacer el reciclaje
para que el impacto sea lo menor posible
claro así que no hay ninguna en realidad
energía que sea tan limpia como uno
pretende sí y bueno y el reciclaje que
es el talón de aquiles no de acá de la
sociedad occidental y en un momento dado
japón compraba para reciclar
también y porque utilizaban ya no
compran más entonces la gente las
grandes empresas están encontrando con
un montón de material que no se puede
reciclar que no tienen la capacidad no
tienen la infraestructura para hacerlo
entonces es complicado porque estamos
desde otro punto de vista pudriendo el
planeta o sea estamos en definitiva sin
escapatorias para poder generar energías
limpias y que sean renovables y que no
produzcan ningún tipo de polución
hay todo un debate ahora en la
actualidad aquí en esta ciudad y en que
ve que en la provincia de québec porque
con esto de la legalización de la
marihuana no de que puede del 17 de
octubre que la marihuana es legal la
venta de la marihuana es legal aquí en
el público y se la fumaron todas se la
fumaron todas pero lo que el debate no
es la escasez aunque si se debate mucho
que la gente dice que pasó nos
prendieron nos dejaron colgado de la
brocha pero la crítica la así es en todo
el desperdicio que se hace de plástico
porque para un gramo de de marihuana lo
envuelven en un recipiente plástico que
viene envuelto en una caja de cartón que
en fin
hay para un gramo de se calcula que por
un gramo de marihuana hay alrededor de
38 o 40 gramos de envoltorio wow que
también está legal el gobierno la ley
045 dentro del cuerpo de la ley del
espíritu de la ley se puede sembrar
cuatro plantas en casa pero el gobierno
que ve que se está contra de eso el
gobierno que pensé no aceptas las de
hecho hay un problema legal ahí y en el
que finalmente en un momento dado se va
a encontrar la legislación de que ve con
la de canadá y bueno ya sabemos quiénes
van a perder no pero ese es otro debate
y 6 claro si se consume tu producción
personal pues a lo mejor no no pero
igual o sea están en todo porque el
gobierno de canal de quebec por ejemplo
entrega una subvención de ocho mil
dólares para quien compra un auto
un electrodo eléctrico como reciclamos
la batería de los autos eléctricos o sea
de los paneles solares seguimos con lo
mismo
la mente mente es complejo la ecuación
es muy compleja no había que tomar en
cuenta también la proporcionalidad de
las cosas no porque evidentemente no hay
energía que no deje residuos
contaminantes pero la proporción por
ejemplo de un carro eléctrico baterías
incluidas no va a ser y su grado de
contaminación de un carro con lo que
responda al gas carbónico efectivamente
no ahora pero en el caso de que tengas
un 90 por ciento de tu planta automotriz
del mundo con baterías donde tiras las
baterías cuando nos sirvan
hay que legislar claro eso es la
legislación bueno pablito
si yo yo ss los invito a escuchar una
entrevista que hice con un bailarín
coreógrafo francés que está
presentándose en este momento aquí en
canadá hoy da su espectáculo en la
ciudad de vancouver comienza este
viernes viernes y sábado presenta un
espectáculo que se llama borderline
de danza contemporánea
es muy particular no he visto el
espectáculo pero sí vi los vídeos que me
enviaron y es muy particular porque
ellos son bailarines de hip hop
inicialmente entonces dentro de su
coreografía integra mucho los
movimientos de hip hop pero lo
particular es que además de eso tienen
un sistema de cuerdas que se adaptan a
la cintura un arnés como un arnés exacto
y que le permite dar saltos increíbles y
figuras aéreas entonces la danza que es
muy de suelo como lo es el hip hop
entonces
de momento tú ves que ellos uno el
bailarín salta y se va de espaldas y se
desplaza en el espacio de una forma que
no es digamos
la tradicional y más natural entonces
ahora se ve hay de cierta forma pero
este es el entrenamiento y se ven las
cuerdas pero en el espectáculo como ven
está el escenario es oscuro y no se ven
esas cuerdas no en el movimiento
entonces es muy particular como danza de
que se mezcla todo lo moderno en parte
del hip hop y se le da a este aspecto
aéreo también como las películas chinas
que saltan y van de un techo a otro
decido si se mueve
si eso es lo que yo los invitaba a decir
borderline a escuchar la entrevista con
sebastián ramírez de la compañía juan
ramírez estamos borderline con diseño de
finalizar y tenemos acá gilberto
martínez no saludos y saludos a canadá
de las américas café man y mapfre de ser
el che ver día también nos manda su
saludo y lisandro che dice opinión
energías alternativas si bien no existe
el impacto ambiental cero insinuar que
las nuevas energías verdes son
que las tradicionales sus fósiles es una
argumentación falaz que por maxim y max
la maldad maximalismo y exigencia de
perfección anula la gran mejora del
medio ambiente que esas nuevas
tecnologías suponen si acá no quisimos
decir o por lo menos y lo dijimos no fue
la intención que no es bueno al
contrario se están buscando las maneras
de que esa en esas energías verdes
renovables o más puras o más sanas
necesitan de una legislación para que
sean mejores todavía desde ningún punto
de vista dijimos no a las nuevas si a
las viejas sino que hay que buscar la
manera de que sean mejores todavía y
bueno eso fueron todos los comentarios
que tenemos ahí pendientes sí sí sí sí
bueno en los controles técnicos hoy
chantal sensor ver en la música les
recuerdo que esta vez la versión audio
de este programa estará en línea hoy
mismo y tendremos la música de kid y la
pusimos un poco nostálgicos y dylan que
recibió esta semana justamente la orden
de la excelencia de alberta fue
recompensada
eso fue todo por hoy les decimos hoy ya
nos despedimos de prisma las últimas
meses
bueno entonces adiós a los amigos de
prima saludos y bueno y allí gracias a
ustedes por ella por su amable de
sintonía chau adiós